do you think we really ever actually
experience
anyone else truly or are we just always
experiencing ourself
or a varying degree of ourself well
there is no difference is the first
thought that came to me there's no
difference i mean there's a difference
between personality or hair length or
but there is no difference you know the
whole
metaphor of we're all a bunch of
snowflakes falling out of the same cloud
you know
so but i do believe
that there can be a state of awareness
and consciousness that is brought
where there can be a a real beholding i
do believe that's possible in the human
body i do
beautiful it doesn't it you know and and
it's i think the degree to which we can
stop the thoughts of assessing
and labeling and judging and those are
all normal things super normal
but if there can be some breaks or those
voices
get a little quieter and then we're just
sitting consciousness aware of
consciousness sitting
then we have this dire this direct
experience with what's across from us
whether it's a human or a bookshelf or
a light you know it becomes very filled
with wonder and awe
you know it's almost like if we're both
looking at a sunset
and there's birds flying we're just
having a direct experience no words just
direct
experience with that color or that
sensuality
and then if one of us goes oh it's 5 p.m
and the sun's about to go down all of a
sudden we're in the
we're in our head about it it's not as
direct of an experience with that so
so as best as i can if i if i can tell
that i'm just projecting all over my
husband or
or my friends which i do every day um
um getting really really still and just
beholding almost like we're a martian
that just landed here which by the way
is
it's not that far from being able to
happen but but it's like it's like
landing on this earth for the first time
and
you ever have that where you're on an
airplane or you're driving hello
and you're just like how's this even
possible that i can go this fast
i literally look up to this guy and see
an airplane and go
why would we think it was so weird if it
was an extraterrestrial craft like why i
mean that thing's flying through the air
yeah so i mean to me that's
you know approaching life with that kind
of wonder and that kind of
mind-blown-ness you know people are like
if you could just be one emoji what
would it be and i was like
the mind-blown emoji my mind is
constantly freaking blind it's beautiful
well it comes through and you know your
music resonates with so many
so i'm grateful for your process and
thank you for
sharing and and opening your heart and
being vulnerable
and you know i love hearing stories
about you know hearing a story about
writing
like back in the day and being like
asked you whether or not it was true or
not and you're like yeah it's true and
like
yeah it's well then it's not coming out
of the lyrics
right i'm not gonna ask your favorite
song because i don't think that's very
easy it's like a child right but is
there one that you were the most afraid
to release that felt the most
vulnerable well hands clean is a song
about
basically statutory rape um the the
record company people were like oh let's
do a video where it's karaoke with
little with some
some kids in there and i remember saying
did you
listen to the song uh
you know apparently not everyone is a
lyric person so when hands clean came
out i got terrified
about thinking that that would require
me to
speak more often on you know this was
however many
15 years 10 years before me too happened
maybe
so i was scared my palms were sweaty but
i'm always scared
i'm never not scared i mean
i don't think i'm ever not afraid it
doesn't mean i'm not gonna do it
that's good advice right there thank you
for that
i will take that and run with it yes you
already
have by the way or drive with it yes
wait time's over no more driving
yeah what's next few oh my god i want to
interview you anytime
anytime